hi there steve coffin here
[Music]
i'm going to talk about managing
expectations in language learning
remember if you like these videos please
subscribe you can even
click on that bell to get notifications
and of course you can always come and
join me at link which is where i learn
languages
so um you know last time i spoke about
uh oh speaking of managing expectations
i've been on my arabic challenge
and doing a lot of listening and reading
and i definitely have the feeling that
i'm getting better slowly slowly i feel
i might be turning a corner
um i may not be you know but uh i like
to feel that i am turning a corner i'd
like to see that i'm
maintaining my routine i'm being active
and i've even started speaking now uh
spoken three four times with muhammad in
egypt
and next week at the end of the first
month of my 90 day challenge then i
think i'll see if i can persuade
muhammad to appear with me
in arabic so you can get a sense of my
progress to date and then i'll do the
same after the second month and after
the third month
my expectations are all i really want to
achieve here in this uh
90-day challenge is that i understand
more of these
arabic podcasts when i listen to them
i can understand them when i read them
and i look up words and there's fewer
and fewer
unknown words so i really do understand
them quite well
i've been listening to a podcast and
reading about the discussions in doha
where they're trying to uh you know the
emirates is trying to be a sort of a
mediator in afghanistan and try to bring
about some kind of a peace between the
taliban and the afghanistan government
so i've heard interviews with you know
abdullah abdullah who's i think the
president or whatever he is prime
minister of afghanistan with someone
from the ministry of uh foreign affairs
in
the emirates
and all of that is fun to listen to and
i just want to understand more that's my
expectation
now
a lot of people get very frustrated
because they aren't as good as they
would like to be
uh you know and and i was speaking to a
chinese
you know a lady who teaches chinese but
we were speaking in english and she was
saying you know she lives in thailand
and when she's together with a group of
thai people and they're all speaking
very quickly then she doesn't understand
very well even though she's quite fluent
in thai
and and i said well that's normal you
know you shouldn't have the expectation
that you can you're not going to be in
on every little thing that they're doing
that's they've lived with the language
since they were small they have things
they talk about references expressions
and stuff that you're not going to pick
up on so that's normal one shouldn't
feel
unhappy and i i see that quite a lot
people who have expectations of
themselves
uh you know i lived in japan for nine
years i would say for the first three
four five years it was difficult for me
to understand japanese sitcoms because
that's a japanese environment a context
that i'm not familiar with i could have
business conversations one-on-one or i
could even be with a group of japanese
business people who were talking about
lumber or economic things and i
understood it all but in that other
context i was not able to do it all and
and so i shouldn't have the expectation
that i can just jump in there and and
be comfortable if i wanted to be better
at that then i'd have to spend a lot of
time
watching japanese sitcoms
so that i would become more and more
familiar with that context
so i think uh you know even in terms of
you know usage
you're going to have mistakes
and um
i guess it depends on what the what the
demands are if you work for a large
corporation let's say in germany or in
in the us or in france or in japan
then i think the expectations are quite
high because you represent that company
you know as a foreigner i mean if you
are that is to say if you are a person
living in japan your expectations for
japanese or for german in germany or for
english in north america would be quite
high but if you are a japanese person or
a german person or a french person and
you're communicating in english with
someone
and that i've often had that experience
then i think the expectations are not so
great you can have mistakes it doesn't
really matter
so another part of managing expectations
is so first of all don't beat up on
yourself because any negative any
frustration is just going to delay your
learning is going to make it less fun
for you you're going to spend less time
at it
it never bothers me when i don't
understand these podcasts that i'm
listening to i know that i'm gradually
getting better
so i don't get upset at myself so i'm
managing my expectations
and your expectations have to relate to
the
goal like what are you going to use the
language for i'm sitting here in
vancouver by the way behind me is the
ocean
i just went for a swim it's getting a
little nippy now you know the
temperature of the water was 15 degrees
celsius 15 something i looked it up sort
of like 60 degrees
uh in the summer it goes up to like 64
65 which is closer to 18 degrees celsius
which is comfortable uh cool but
comfortable
and it gets warmer as you swim
when it's uh 15 degrees
it doesn't get warmer as you swim you
get colder
but you feel refreshed afterwards
uh but anyway leaving that aside
uh so that the other part of managing
expectations is
you know you should have expectations of
yourself in terms of your activities
now different people are going to
progress at different rates some might
be better in pronunciation some might be
better in acquiring vocabulary maybe
they read more widely or or whatever but
what you can control is your level of
activity that's why this 90-day
challenge i'm telling myself like i'm
trying to i'm trying i'm not always
meeting it but i'm trying to save a
hundred links that is to say on link i
save 100 new words
and i move 100 words to known like i
want to end up with 100 words that have
moved from you know words that i have
saved that are in my database to where
they're known
what i'm doing for those of you who are
on link what i do to make that happen is
as i'm reading on link i try to move my
words along to status three status three
is close to gnome
so they go from one when you first find
them they're one later on you might move
them to two they get a little lighter
yellow then i move them to three and
they're even lighter yellow and so if i
move all more and more words to the
status three then i can go to my
vocabulary section
i can sort for just status three words
and i can even you know and i go in
there and i start going through them and
i find that a lot of the status three
words now i know and so i move them to
note
and i don't worry if i move it to no one
and then later on i don't know it again
i move it back it doesn't matter but the
net effect of all of that is that i'm
reviewing these words that i'm close to
being able to say that i know
i'm trying to get a hundred of them so
i'm controlling my activity
and if i
think i know it today and i've forgotten
it tomorrow that again doesn't bother me
i don't have the expectation that
everything that i learn i will learn
forever
my expectation is that whatever i learn
a good portion or some of that i'm going
to forget again and and relearn so
that's fine too i accept that as as part
of you know my expectation the other
thing you can do in terms of uh
you know your expectations your
activities
i always quote this lady i can't
remember her name but she was the head
of the language department at the
university of san diego whom i met at
this
uh
american society
teaching a foreign languages or whatever
and she said there's only three things
that matter in language learning the
attitude of the learner the time spent
with the language so if you read a
grammar explanation in english that's
not so good if you're listening in the
language if you're speaking in the
language so time spent with the language
and then this business of noticing so
you have to want to notice so my father
for example who came from czechoslovakia
i moved to canada lived here for 30 odd
years spoke english very very well but
he had certain expressions that he would
never change like he would say
play it by the ear
it's play it by ear in english he would
play it by his ear like that was uh to
him and he never really got the th
and play it by the ear he got used to
saying that
and uh you know he would always say ward
and work instead of word and work
now if you're noticing what's happening
in the language
if you notice things
you have a chance of improving that
doesn't mean i i don't blame my father
he was comfortable he did business he
was fluent he was he was the best in
scrabble he had a tremendous vocabulary
and it didn't bother him that there were
these things that were not
say close to
you know normal usage so that was fine
but if you are concerned about that then
you have to develop the habit of
noticing things you have to spend the
time
you have to be positive therefore don't
beat yourself up when you don't quite do
or you aren't quite as good as you would
like to be have realistic expectations
control your activities
and try to notice what's happening in
the language and if you do all of those
things
then you can manage your expectations i
guess i went on a little bit longer
today anyway bye for now
[Music]